eugène berg ancien diplomate français
bonsoir jalbert merci d'être avec nous
les etats unis qui annonce donc l'envoi
1 confirme l'envoi de 3000 soldats
américains supplémentaires
que peut-on déduire de cette annonce
selon vous
on peut déduire que l'agitation
militaro-diplomatique ne diminue pas et
c'est quand même dommage toute personne
sensée devrait quand même se rendre
compte que pourquoi on fait ce
déployement
pourquoi on fait monter les monter les
enjeux et on ne rentre pas de plain pied
dans une négociation sérieuse
qui portera sur tous les volets de part
et d'autre et malheureusement ce n'est
pas le cas donc on a beaucoup de
réunions tout le monde beaucoup de gens
vont à kiev ce sera le cas de
du président rire de gand le président
turc
on parle également de
deux voyages éventuelle à moscou donc il
ya une agitation qui est un petit peu
qui accroît la tension psychologique
tout autour d'une eux c'est à dire
vraiment une discussion sur tous les
volets élargissement de l'otan
manoeuvres militaires non déplacement
non dépouillement dame offensive ainsi
de suite c'est ça le coeur des
préoccupations
malheureusement il ya une surenchère il
ya les annonces alors puisque vous
parlez de boris johnson s'est presque
ironique
c'est finalement washington qu'il a
rappelés à l'ordre en disant écoutez
vous avez des oligarques il ya un argent
supposé pas tout à fait propre arrêté
finalement d'accueillir et frappé les
amis de monsieur poutine au portefeuille
c'est quand même intéressant de voir que
c'est washington qui rappelle à l'ordre
son plus proche allié ça venait pas
naturellement de londres donc voilà une
explique une difficulté en plus en cas
effectivement 2 le conflit fort peu
probable
mais pourquoi annoncer des sanctions
s'ils nous mêmes enfin si nous même si
les anglais eux mêmes ne sont pas prêts
les supporter pour l'heure pas donc
voila un petit peu une image
malheureusement contraste est là il ya
un viktor orban qui est montrée à
l'écran qui est allé à moscou donc c'est
quelqu'un qui maintient le dialogue il
est critique est évidemment par une
partie mais ça montre que finalement le
dialogue se complexifie et heureusement
qu'il existe il ya différents points de
vue et il faut espérer dans les jours à
venir où les semaines il y aura un
éclaircissement parce qu'effectivement
ça peut pas durer aussi longtemps et ce
serait vraiment en tout cas on entend le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson a toujours prompte à montrer ses
muscles qu'il a c'est un petit peu
radouci semble-t-il ils ont donc parlé
ensemble avec venir continuent
aujourd'hui se sont accordés sur la
nécessité de trouver une résolution
pacifique à cette crise emmanuel macron
lui va parler à joe biden est dit
aujourd'hui n'exclut pas d'aller en
russie ça veut dire que ça va peut-être
passer par l'europe cette résolution
finalement
ça va pas passer par l'europe mais
l'europe qui était absent dès le départ
s'introduit dans le débat et c'est bien
parce que finalement c'est elle qui est
concerné c'est quand même les pays
européens roumanie pologne sur lesquels
il ya un déploiement militaire américain
et vous faites allusion ou quelques
milliers de soldats enfin c'est pas là
le problème le problème c'est des armes
et si les missiles à courte portée que
ou alors dd est une arme anti missiles
déployés là aux portes de la russie
c'est ça qu'elle cherche finalement un
résoudre le problème que que les pays
membres de l'otan qui sont proches de
ses frontières ne soit pas utilisé pour
une agression éventuelles contre elle
c'est ça le coeur donc il faut que
l'europe sous une modalité à trouver
puisque l'europe finalement n'a pas de
force militaire elle n'est qu'une astres
un instrument diplomatique assez divisés
d'ailleurs pas tout à fait unis entre
elles mais il faut qu'elles aient voix
au chapitre dans un règlement global qui
prendra du temps qui s'esquisse déjà
puisque il ya différentes par exemple el
país dit qu'il ya déjà des avancées que
les américains sont prêts à accorder
certaines garanties
il ya les lisez aussi a été très prudent
lors de l'entretien de la semaine
dernière en disant que oui monsieur
macron à écouter et il est prêt
également à étudier certaines garanties
que
l'occident c'est à dire autant et union
européenne pourrait apporter à à vladmir
poutine à la russie dont le dialogue est
là il commence il est très lent
évidemment je ne qualifierais pas et il
a une vitesse de sénateurs d'escargots
néanmoins il ya un dialogue qui
compliquait encore une fois il a
tellement de canaux mais on peut on peut
envisager effectivement dans les jours à
venir s'il ya d'autres entretiens de
passer à une phase peut-être un peu plus
confidentiels tout ça ce sont des bruits
se sont appelés un conte fumée et on va
arriver à une discussion entre experts
en 30 politique et qui va peut-être se
concentrer sur l'essentiel enfin en tout
cas c'est le voeu qu'on peut formuler et
je crois déceler quelques
jadis qui sembleraient montrer qu' on a
pris ce chemin avec prudence tout en
proclamant qu au cas où on prend dans
les sanctions dont il ya une espèce de
double jeu et il faudrait que le disons
la joute verbale diminue pour laisser
plus de champ ou négociation très
experts et autres responsables merci
beaucoup aux jeunes berg ancien
diplomate français merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
ce décryptage